We start the search for
a deeper understanding,
with the idea of the augmenting path.
Recall that in our original
treatment of the max flow problem,
we were given a flow over some graph,
and we defined the residual network,
which captured the ways in which we
were allowed to modify this flow.
This included adding backwards edges
that went in the opposite direction from
edges in the original.
Augmenting paths then were paths
over this residual network
that went from the source to the sync,
and augmented the flow.
In a network that arises from
a bipartite matching problem,
there are few special phenomena
that are worth noting.
First observe that all intermediate
flows found by Ford-Fulkerson
correspond to matchings as well.
If there is flow across an internal
edge, then it belongs in the matching.
Also because flows along
edges are either zero or
one there are no anti-parallel
edges in the residual network.
That is to say either
the original edge is there or
the reverse edge is there, never both.
Moreover the matched edges are the ones
that have their edges reversed.
Also, only unmatched vertices have
an edge from the source to them,
or from them to the sync.
Matched vertices have
their edges reversed.
The result of all this is that
any augmenting path must start
at an unmatched vertex, and
then follow an unmatched edge,
followed by a matched edge,
followed by an unmatched edge,
until eventually it reaches an unmatched
vertex on the right hand side, and
then it can follow
that edge to the sync.
This realization allows us to strip away
much of the complexity of flow networks
and define an augmenting path for
bipartite matching in
more natural terms.
We start by defining the more general
concept of an alternating path.
Given a matching M,
an alternating path is a path where the
edges are alternately in M and not in M.
And an augmenting path is
an alternating path where the first and
the last vertex are unmatched.
For example, in this graph here,
going from this unmatched vertex in L
to this matched vertex in R back
to this matched one in L and
then to this unmatched one in R
constitutes and augmenting path.
We use it to augment the matching
by making the unmatched edges
matched and the matched edges unmatched.
Like so.
This always increases the size of
the matching because before we flipped,
there was one more unmatched edge
than matched edge in the path.
So when we reversed the matched and
unmatched edges, we increased
the size of the matching by one.
In fact,
we can restate the Ford-Fulkerson
method purely in these terms.
We initialize the matching
to the empty set, and then
while there's an augmenting path, we
update the matching to be the symmetric
difference between the current
matching and the path that we found.
The symmetric difference
includes an element
if it's in exactly one of these sets,
or alternatively, you can think
about it as the union of the two sets
minus the things that are in both.
The things that are in both here
correspond to matched edges in the path.
And remember that we flipped
them to being unmatched.
And finally,
once there are no more augmenting paths,
we simply return the matching.